pushback is the name you may recognize
he's a highly decorated Navy SEAL a
decade ago he became famous because he
announced he was transitioning becoming
a woman calling himself Kristen back CNN
made a film about him and in that film
Chris back at the time identifying this
woman admitted that he wasn't sure what
the term transgender men watch as Hunter
explained people ask me about that they
say I don't really understand
transgender and you know can you explain
it to me
and the only thing I can tell him is I
don't I don't really know what
transgender is either you know I don't
know I mean I know what it is it's this
but I don't know like where it comes
from or why
so Chris Beck has had 10 years to think
about this and he looks back and
believes and is said that the whole
process of transitioning quote destroyed
his life in an interview with Robbie
Starbuck Beck said this quote everything
that happened to me for the last 10
years destroyed my life I destroyed my
life I'm not a victim I did this to
myself but I had help
respect joins us now Chris thanks so
much for coming on
um it's a poignant story and deserves I
think a much longer treatment than we're
about to give it but when you say you
had help what did you mean by that
well the transgender originally started
out and you know pretty basic and very
rare and now it's kind of morphed into
an ideology and that's what I'm kind of
speaking out of that thinking about the
ideology I'm not talking about the
people now there's a lot of transgender
people great folks but the ideology was
I'm talking about it's it's becoming
something where it's being pushed in
schools and young teenagers are having
surgeries because it's sand or
transgender it's an affirmation once a
teenager walks into an office even if
the parents are saying no that doctor
can override that and that's a problem
so then you also just to say to ideology
and what's going on to prove it is like
what's happened to me as soon as I
started speaking out and saying that I
think these teenagers need more time
they also need to reclassify transgender
it's gender dysphoria it used to be in
uh you know the psychologist's manual
for you know mental health issues now
they've gotten rid of that and now as
soon as somebody goes in there and says
anything even close to transgender
you're basically level transgender and
you start pushing your surgery that's
what I'm trying to stop there's a lot of
great people out there who are
transgender not transferred to
everything what I'm talking about when I
talk about CNN is that they take sound
bites they take something and they talk
about it one-sided they talk about all
the pros of transgender now I'm on Fox
didn't want to do this but now on Fox I
don't want it to happen the opposite way
what we need to do is take a pause for
this we want to take the emotions out of
this and just look at it as a medical
team let's look at it through a lot of
different scope I don't want this to be
political and I don't want transgender
people to be harmed but if you're doing
this to kids that's wrong I have a Navy
SEAL friend of mine a very good friend
of mine he has a daughter the daughter
was a tomboy you could see it she was a
happy tomboy she had double mastectomy
at 16 years old a Navy SEAL friend of
mine now this person is 20 I think and
who knows what's going to happen but
they also start doing them on hormone
blockers and all kinds of other hormone
things puberty blockers everything else
it sterilizes these kids
so we're going to have all these
children in five or ten years who are
being told one side of this story and
they're going well that's me because
they're not being told stories like mine
they're not being stolen towards stories
like so many other people who have beat
transitions they hide the fact that I
even exist they also say that I hate
transgender people I don't hate
transgender people there's a lot of my
friends what I care about is people I
want people to slow down I want these
doctors to see what they're doing in
Psychology take a look at gender
dysphoria take a look at autogonophilia
take a look at body that's perfect uh
disorder there's a myriad of things you
can look at
I'm sorry
that we really have to start taking a
look at so what I'm telling is the
medical industry and parents you all
need to wake up you all need to know
that there's a lot of information out
there that's being hidden I don't want
you to search for that information if
you're a teenager look at the stories
like Chloe Cole she's 18 or 19 now but I
think she had a double mastectomy at
like 14 or 15 years old look up that
name Cody Cole she's out here speaking
about it because she's an adult now so
if she's getting all this done as a
teenager where does that put the medical
industry she was not a concerning adult
and she got life-altering surgery she
got basically you know castrated as a
teenager with all these drugs and all
the stuff they're giving them why all
I'm speaking out about is that I want
people to take a look at both sides I
want you to see the CNN side I don't
want you to see the fox side right now
this is not political I don't want to be
political I I don't want to be emotional
I don't want this to turn into something
bigger than it is this should not be
news if doctors would be honest and give
the entire story then I wouldn't even be
on here right now I would have gone
about my life quietly I would have been
on my farm you never would have heard
from me Tucker I don't want to talk to
you I don't want to be on here but yeah
we have to be here because nobody is
standing up for these kids
now if there's a bunch of kids that are
transgender and they grow up and be
happy and they're 80 years old and
they're still happy you know that's
great but there's a lot of kids are
getting caught up in this huge tidal
wave of popular transgender culture
popular transgender ideology and that is
wrong
that's what I'm talking about
what you've just expressed is the
opposite of hate it's measured and
thoughtful and Humane and born of your
own experience and clearly motivated by
good faith and I hope it's seen by
everyone because it's not political
you're absolutely right respect I
appreciate your thinking that through
and sharing with us what you've learned
and what you hope for the country thank
you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight